and our next guest takes bargain hunting
to new heights on tick tock and this
year alone she's saved more than ten
thousand dollars
take a look
whoever said nothing in life is free has
clearly never met kayla i have a deal
for you coupons with kayla's tick tock
spills all the tea on scoring the best
deals out there but if coffee is more
your taste then there's a deal for that
too
from clothing and shoes to self-care and
food kayla's got the tips for her
impressive 2 million followers hosting a
dinner party why not get your
ingredients for free does someone have
new shoes on their wish list how about
getting them for 50 off want to get all
made up for a date night look like a
million bucks for only 99 cents if
frugal fun is what you seek then
brilliant kayla is your go-to girl
and she's here live and in person it's
caleb
tick-tock superstar
and your first couponing experience um
the store actually gave you money to
leave with the product what yeah i went
to the store and i went to go get a
loofah just to try it out i love that
yeah and i gave them a coupon and they
gave me back money and i was like i'm
gonna have to start doing this
okay so what are some of the biggest
items that you've gotten from couponing
i've gotten a lot of things on sale um
just recently i started a gym in my home
because i got two thousand dollars worth
of gym equipment for sixty dollars
whoa how
uh coupons there was it was like promo
codes online and it was just like this
one brand just had a whole bunch of
promo codes and it just like the money
just kept going down and down down and i
was like i'll take it thank you for
doing what you're doing
really and truly all right so we're
right here right now we've got this
awesome table take us through it you're
in the driver's seat i'm your passenger
teach me okay we'll start with this
first section here okay so this the
first tip we're going to talk about is
stacking coupons okay so these are
things you would find like in-store so
in-store you have like manufacturer
coupons and you have store coupons and
there's a lot of stores that will let
you use two of those one of each on one
item
so it's like double savings and then you
can get the coupons on the app so if
you're going to a store um kind of just
download the app and there will be a
section where you can get all the
coupons super easy to make it super
convenient so when you stack all of them
on an item it makes it like super cheap
so for example if we have some
toothpaste let's say it's like five
dollars and you go on the app and
there's a two dollar coupon and you're
like okay but then you go on that like
the
um ad the weekly ad and they're like hey
if you buy this item we'll give you
three dollars in points and then so the
two dollar coupon the three dollar in
points that's now free 100 free but my
favorites
my absolute favorite thing to buy are
money makers an example would be like
these razors so let's say let's get
specific like six dollars 29 cents for
these razors and you go on the app and
there's a five dollar coupon so that
makes it super cheap you're like a
dollar twenty nine that's that's great
but then you look in the ad and let's
say they also say hey buy this item
we'll give you three dollars and points
so you made money now yeah because
you're paying a dollar twenty nine but
they're giving you three dollars so
that's more than you paid and then you
like just
accumulate those points and i use those
extra points that they give me yeah to
buy other things that i need that are
kind of hard to get on sale so like
toilet paper is a great example um you
can get it like 50 off every now and
then but like it's really hard to get
for free
so what i like to do is i like to use
that free like money type stuff that
they're giving us and use it on items
like that to get it super cheap super
free so that's amazing yeah amazing
okay what is this plate of pastry okay
so
i love this this is uh the second tip is
birthdays uh there are so many things
you can get for free on your birthday
really so much stuff what you want to do
is you want to like sign up for emails
for different companies and then either
like the day of your birthday or like
the beginning of the month so like my
birthday is may 19th so may 1st i'll
start getting emails saying hey it's
your birthday month here's like ten
dollars to spend on our store or here's
a 30 off coupon anything that month but
then the pastries and stuff are here
because the other thing you can get free
all day is food all day from the time
you wake up to the time you go to sleep
free food all day long really yeah
because let's because they'll send you
emails and stuff and so um
like
on my birthday last year i started the
day off with um coffee i got a free
coffee and then there are places where
you can get pastries donuts i know like
a stack of pancakes so like breakfast i
know there's places that give like free
wings free sandwiches so there's like
lunch dinner and then the amount of
places that give you dessert like
brownies ice cream there's so many and
so you just sign up for their emails and
they'll send it to you and then you if
you're if you are hungry by the end of
the day on your birthday
there's a problem you do something yeah
you did something wrong i love that
kayla what's your third tip okay
the third one
is online stuff you want to follow like
companies on social media because
sometimes they'll post like either like
flash deals or coupons stuff like that
my favorite one that has happened
recently uh people don't even believe me
when i say it is there is a company who
would give a 99 off coupon up to like a
certain amount and so this year i got my
boyfriend a sweater and it was
originally 30
and ended up being 30 cents for the
sweater because of the coupon and but
you wouldn't have known that it was
happening unless you were following them
on social media
so that's why it's like super important
to do that okay and then and then like
also like signing up for emails are so
important for coupons um because like
okay so you have like oh those are so
cool these are my doggies so they're so
adorable that's douglas and lucy right
there but you can get prints like that
all the time like every month i'm
getting like free prints because i'll
get an email and they'll say hey here's
a coupon code go online like type it in
and then order it and it'll be free so
some people think it's really hard to
like coupon yeah and whatnot um so
it can be intimidating but there are
there are rebate apps that you can get
that you go on your phone and you go to
the store and you just um like take a
receipt take a picture and it'll give
you points there's a couple of them that
i like there's a shopkick and fetch
rewards and basically all you do is for
shopkick it'll tell you a bunch of
different items and they'll say hey go
to the store buy this item and then show
us a picture of your receipt showing
proving that you bought it and we'll
give you points and in those points you
just get gift cards and then fetch
rewards is the same just everything i'm
buying
just turns into gift cards okay well i
just think that you are such a game
changer and i'm so glad that you're out
there kind of laying the breadcrumbs so
that other people can partake in all of
the hard work
that you're doing
you're lighting the way thank you caleb
i so appreciate it
[Music]